Y
AVERAGE OF NEW CASES NOW TOPPING
120,000.
NOW TO ANOTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT, MONKEYPOX.
HEALTH OFFICIALS HAVE IDENTIFIED
NEARLY 3,500 CASES HERE IN THE
U.S.
REMEMBER, THE FIRST CASE HERE IN
THE U.S. WAS DISCOVERED JUST TWO
MONTHS AGO.
WE'RE LEARNING THE WHITE HOUSE
IS NOW EXPECTED TO NAME A
COORDINATOR TO OVERSEE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE, A
RESPONSE THAT EVEN DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI SAYS NEEDS TO IMPROVE.
>> THERE NOW HAS TO BE A BALANCE
BETWEEN VACCINES AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE WHO CLEARLY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED AS WELL AS THOSE AT
RISK, AND THAT'S WHERE NOW THE
CHANGE AND THE DISTRIBUTION SO
THAT YOU ANTICIPATE THAT SOMEONE
MIGHT GET INFECTED AS OPPOSED TO
RESPONDING TO SOMEONE WHO IS
INFECTED.
>> DR. FAUCI ALSO MENTIONED A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
DECLARATION FOUR MONKEYPOX IS
UNDER ACTIVE CONSIDERATION.
KYLE PLANK IS RECOVERING FROM
MONKEYPOX.
HE STARTED FEELING SICK IN JUNE,
WAS DIAGNOSED IN EARLY JULY.
HE'S JOINING US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU ARE FULLY RECOVERED,
RIGHT?
>> I AM, THANKFULLY.
>> ANY RESIDUAL ISSUES?
>> NOT REALLY.
I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF SCAR
TISSUE WHERE SOME OF THE LESIONS
WERE.
I'M HOPEFUL IT WILL GET BETTER
IN NO TIME.
>> TELL US HOW YOU LEARNED YOU
HAD MONKEYPOX.
>> I WORK IN THE INFECTIOUS
DISEASES SPACE.
I'M DOING RESEARCH AND WITH
BEING A GAY MAN IN NEW YORK
CITY, MONKEYPOX IS ON MY MIND
MORE THAN THE AVERAGE PERSON
PERHAPS.
I WAS AWARE IT WAS HAPPENING IN
EUROPE AND AFTER PRIDE WHEN I
STARTED TO FEEL SICK I CAME DOWN
WITH SOME SYMPTOMS, GENERIC FLU
LIKE SYMPTOMS AND I WAS WORRIED
I HAD COVID.
IN THE BACK OF MY MIND, PERHAPS
THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE, PERHAPS
IT'S MONKEYPOX, AND THE SPOTS
STARTED TO APPEAR.
>> WE HAVE PICTURES OF THE
SPOTS.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE MORE HOW THEY
DIFFER FROM OTHER RASHES,
BLISTERS?
>> THE PROGRESSION MOVED REALLY
QUICKLY.
THEY LOOKED ALMOST LIKE PIMPLES
WHEN THEY FIRST APPEARED AND
TURNED INTO POSTULES BY THE END
OF THE FIRST DAY.
THEY STARTED ON MY ARMS AND
HANDS BUT SPREAD ALL OVER MY
TRUNK AND I HAD SOME INTERNAL
LESIONS THAT WERE SUPER PAINFUL.
>> IT SOUNDS SO PAINFUL.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THAT?
UP SAID IT WAS THE MOST PAIN
YOU'VE EVER EXPERIENCED.
>> IT WAS.
FOR ABOUT A WEEK I HAD EXTREMELY
SEVERE PAIN, A BURNING SORT OF
PAIN THAT WOULDN'T GO AWAY EVEN
WITH ALTERNATING DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PAINKILLERS AND THAT PAIN
REALLY DIDN'T ABATE UNTIL I GOT
PRESCRIBED AN ANTIVIRAL USED FOR
MONKEYPOX.
>> OKAY.
SO ONCE YOU WERE PRESCRIBED
THAT, WHAT DID THE TREATMENT
ENTAIL?
>> IT'S A 14-DAY COURSE YOU HAVE
TO TAKE WITH A FATTY MEAL TO
HELP WITH THE ABSORPTION.
WITHIN TWO DAYS OF GETTING THE
TREATMENT I STARTED TO FEEL
BETTER AND HATCH OF MY LESIONS
STARTED TO DISAPPEAR RATHER THAN
PROGRESSING TO SCABS LIKE IT
NORMALLY DOES.
GETTING THE DRUG WAS A
COMPLICATED PROCESS A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE NOT ABLE TO DO,
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> THAT BRINGS ME TO THE LETTERS
AND THE OUTREACH THAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO OFFICIALS TRYING TO SAY,
HEY, MORE PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS DRUG, T-POX, MORE
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
HAVE YOU RECEIVED ANY RESPONSE?
AND WHO DID YOU REACH OUT TO?
>> I CAST A WIDE NET FOR SURE.
I WAS REACHING OUT TO OUR
SENATORS AND REPRESENTATIVES
HERE FROM NEW YORK, BUT I ALSO
WROTE LETTERS TO HHS AND CDC
JUST TRYING TO REACH THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE OF THE T-POX RESPONSE
BASICALLY.
I WAS JUST HOPING TO CHANGE THE
PROCEDURE THAT'S REQUIRED FOR
GETTING ACCESS TO T-POX.
>> WAS IT DIFFICULT TO GET
ACCESS?
>> DEFINITELY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A HIGH
SUSPICION OR A POSITIVE
MONKEYPOX TEST IN ORDER TO GET
IT, AND IT REQUIRES HOURS AND
HOURS OF PAPERWORK FOR THE
DOCTORS, ACTUALLY, TO GET IT
FROM THE NATIONAL STOCKPILE.
FOR PEOPLE WHO AREN'T CONNECTED
TO ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS LIKE
ME IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET THIS
EVEN IF YOU'RE IN SEVERE PAIN.
>> WHAT MORE DO YOU THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN DO AS WE
DISCUSSED AT THE TOP OF THE
SEGMENT EVEN DR. FAUCI IS SAYING
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE?
THERE'S TALK OF A MONKEYPOX
COORDINATOR BEING NAMED.
>> I THINK IT'S LIKE INCREASING
VACCINATIONS TO PREVENT THE
DISEASE, INCREASING ACCESS TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK SO THEY
DON'T SPREAD IT FURTHER AND GET
BETTER SOONER, AND INFORMATION
AS WELL.
CDC HAS BEEN WORKING ON AN
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN BUT IT HAS
NOT BEEN AS EFFECTIVE AS WE
WOULD HOPE.
THANKFULLY LAST FRIDAY THEY MADE
IT EASIER TO GET T-POX.
ALM OF THE REQUIREMENTS TO
ENROLL IN THE PROTOCOL SUCH AS
TAKING PICTURES WAS MADE
OPTIONAL.
NEXT STEPS HAVING A FULL-SCALE
CLINICAL TRIAL OF THE EFFICACY
OF THIS DRUG AND MAKING IT
OPTIONAL AND NOT REQUIRED TO GET
ACCESS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
CREATES A BARRIER FOR PEOPLE
HAVING TO HAVE THEIR DOCTORS
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE OF HOW TO
ENROLL THEM IN THIS TRIAL IN
ORDER TO GET ACCESS.
>> DO YOU FEE THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS A HANDLE ON THIS AT THIS
POINT?
>> I THINK THE WHEELS ARE
DEFINITELY IN MOTION.
UNFORTUNATELY, TOO LATE.
I THINK THE OUTBREAK CAN STILL
BE CONTAINED BUT WILL TAKE
DRAMATIC ACTION ON THE PART OF
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES GETTING
VACCINES AND TREATMENT OUT TO
PEOPLE QUICKLY.
I THINK THERE WAS A WINDOW IN
EARLY MAY AND JUNE TO CONTROL IT
THAT WE MISSED AND NOW IT'S A
LOT LARGER OF A PROBLEM THAN WE
HAD HOPED.
WE NEED TO TAKE BOLD ACTION TO
GET IT UNDER CONTROL.
>> KYLE PLANCK, THANK YOU FOR
SH